in his first trip out of mainland china
since kova began president xi is set to
meet with vladimir putin tomorrow in
uzbekistan
the topic the war in ukraine
and to quote show an alternative to the
western world arkansas senator tom
cotton member of the house judicial
senate judiciary committee joins us now
senator um
is it wrong to suggest that biden's
failures
have driven these two into the arms of
each other
laura that's not wrong at all it's very
dangerous it's been a cardinal principle
of american foreign policy from the
beginning that we don't want a nation or
coalition of nations like dictatorships
in russia and china to unite in the old
world with the ability to command its
resources and territories and people to
strike us here in the new world but joe
biden's weakness throughout all of 2021
towards russia itself and on display
last year in the debacle in afghanistan
enticed vladimir putin to invade ukraine
and that's what created the conditions
for these two countries to potentially
grow closer together vladimir putin is
turning to china looking for assistance
not only in technology and weapons but
also to buy the oil and gas that he
needs to keep his economy afloat which
leads me to the second biden failure
which is biden's war on american energy
on oil and gas and coal rather than
europe facing a dark cold winter we
could be supplying them with natural gas
to help power their homes and power
their factories yet we're waging war
here in america on our own domestic
energy production while at the same time
we are making ourselves beholden and
dependent to chinese energy because
china has most of the world's so-called
green energy technology market cornered
both of these key failures have helped
create the conditions for russia and
china to grow closer together which is
gravely dangerous for america's freedom
safety and prosperity
are you confident that uh old mayor pete
senator is going to be able to handle
this rail strike i mean last time i
checked he's looking for somewhere to
plug in his ev or you know hop on his
bike and bike to work or something
that's cute but it doesn't really solve
the energy problems yeah or the real
problem let's remember first off that
whether it whether it's a so-called
electric vehicle or electric scooter
that secretary boudijed just driving to
work this week it's not really electric
powered vehicles it's coal powered
vehicle vehicles natural gas powered
vehicles because the electricity comes
from somewhere and no i don't have
confidence that either he or joe biden
can avert what could be a very serious
strike of railroad workers i mean by
some estimates we're talking two billion
dollars of economic loss every single
day if they go on strike just
barely 24 hours from right now look the
president under federal union or labor
law appointed what's called an emergency
board it made recommendations the
railways have accepted them
most of the unions have accepted them
republican senators today proposed under
federal labor law that we should accept
those recommendations but democrats
blocked us joe biden refuses to take the
step of his own hand-picked emergency
board because he doesn't want to offend
union supporters just two months for an
election
but if railway workers go on strike and
especially if it's a protracted spike
americans are going to be paying even
more
food at the grocery store for basic
goods at other stores because so much
moves on railways across america
so does that mean you don't have
confidence in mayor pete i'm just
kidding like the guy he has no business
being said i worked at the department of
transportation i'm really doing my
resume tonight but i worked there as a
speechwriter many years ago it's a
complicated department i mean it is very
complicated he doesn't know what he's
doing okay and americans are going to
pay the price senator thanks for making
this very clear tonight for us hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else